have you ever wondered the differences
between jenkins and tekton
hi i'm christine and today i'm going to
talk to y'all about the differences
between the two
two ci cd tools that have the same goal
just achieve them in different ways
let's start with the basics to
understand jenkins and tecton we first
need to understand continuous
integration and continuous delivery or
ci cd for short
ci cd is the process of automating
software development through testing
building and deploying applications
jenkins and tecton are two ci cd tools
designed to create what is called ci cd
pipelines
to learn more about continuous
integration and delivery check out the
videos linked below in our description
but for today i'm going to talk to you
guys just about the similarities and the
differences between the two
let's start with tecton
to understand tecton we first need to
understand kubernetes
kubernetes
is a container orchestration platform
designed for automating application
deployment management and scaling
tecton runs on kubernetes allowing you
to work with your cicd processes on the
same cluster as your applications
this allows you to easily scale your
workloads simply by adding nodes to your
cluster
techdon comes with a set of kubernetes
custom resources giving you the building
blocks to easily configure and manage
your pipelines
you can automate tecton either through
the command line or through the tektron
ui in the browser
all right
now let's get into the architecture
so i'm going to start by giving a simple
example to explain ci cd pipelines
better
let's say you have an application that
you want to deploy into production
and you want to automate this process by
using tekton to keep it even simpler
you're going to run the following
procedures on it
you're going to want to test your
application
build it
and then deploy it
each one of these operations becomes a
step
which is the smallest building block of
tucton
steps are where you can specify your
commands your arguments your images to
execute your processes
once you've created your steps you can
organize them into what is called tasks
a single task
you can have one step or multiple steps
depending on the order and sequence you
put them in your files
so
a task
runs
on basically a pod
and a pod is
a single
instance of a running process on your
kubernetes cluster
but we're not going to get into pods or
clusters today if you want to take a
deeper dive
again check out the videos linked below
in our description
so the great thing about tasks is that
once defined
you can reuse them in any pipeline you
want so say i have another pipeline that
i'm working on that's dedicated solely
to testing applications and i want to
use this test task because it has
exactly what i'm trying to do
all i would have to do is reference the
task name in my other pipeline no need
to rewrite anything or duplicate it
all right
so that brings me to the next topic
which is pipelines
and pipelines
are a way of further organizing
your tasks by
controlling the execution of them
pipelines allow you to organize tasks
concurrently or sequentially depending
on the order they're placed
and pipelines and tasks are techton
custom resources that allow you to
control what gets inputted and what gets
outputted from the tasks
for example an input would be the source
code of your application that you're
running through the pipeline and an
example of an output would be
the image produced from your build task
okay so inputs and outputs these are
called pipeline resources and you can
define them in your tasks or your
pipelines or you can put them in their
own file depending how organized you
want to get
okay
so pipelines organize the execution of
tasks
tasks organize the execution of steps
and steps execute what you're trying to
do
how can we automate this process even
further what fires off
our pipeline
so a concept called a pipeline run
run triggers our pipeline and you can
declare that in the trigger template
and tecton
triggers
allow you to detect and extract
information
from
events from various sources that allow
you to execute your tasks and pipelines
so what exactly does that mean
an event an example of an event would be
let's say we want to fire off this
pipeline every time one of our
developers
commits changes to the code
there's a concept called the event
listener
which listens to specific events in this
case it will be listening to our
developer committing code
once that happens it will pick it up
and it will fire off our pipeline
all right
so as you can see
tecton
its process is very structured
to put it even more visually
each one of these concepts is just a
file
the event listener the trigger template
the pipeline in each individual task is
its own file a yaml file to be exact
and that's one of the biggest features
of tekton is that it's object oriented
it's modular it makes it very easy to
reuse and and customize and organize and
it's it's super flexible
okay
so
i'm going to touch on one more thing
before we get into jenkins and that is
storage
how or where does tecton store its ci cd
data
the answer to that is workspaces
all right so workspaces
or let me back up
when we think of storage
for techton think of basically a very
large file system okay
and workspaces allow tasks to declare
part of that file system to use for
storage
what are we storing the inputs and the
outputs throughout this whole process
to take it a step further there's a
concept called a persistent volume claim
pvc
which lets you specifically define the
location of that storage volume
and it lets tasks share them amongst the
process
and you can
typically define these in the trigger
template
one more thing that you can also define
in our trigger template is service
accounts and service accounts basically
handle secrets or authentication with
techton
so you've got passwords you've got
tokens you've got ssh keys and you want
to make sure everything is is secure
before you run your steps techton runs
this credential initialization on each
pod before it executes steps keeping
your whole process secure which is very
important
all right
so let's get into jenkins now that we've
got a good understanding of tecton
the biggest difference between the two
is that while techton runs on kubernetes
jenkins runs on its own servers
or vms
virtual machines
so
a part of tecton running on kubernetes
means that
it's made up of many different languages
like node python ruby java
jenkins however is based solely on java
you might be wondering how can jenkins
even stand up to techton if it only
supports features written in java
the answer to that is plugins
jenkins plugins extend the capability of
projects written in languages other than
java
so say for example you want to use a
version control system like github
you would need to install the github
plugin on your jenkins machine to work
with it
super easy to install there's over a
thousand different jenkins plugins
and you manage them and install them
through what's called the jenkins ui
similar to tecton you can work with
jenkins through the ui or the command
line but mostly people use the ui
and on the ui
is where you can
manage your pipelines
okay
so
in that sense it's very similar but when
it comes to the file structure that's
where they differ
jenkins stores
its configurations in what's called a
jenkins file which is one
large
file
like so
so
going off the same
example i used over here
you've got an application that you want
to deploy to production
and you want to automate this process
but this time using jenkins
what you would do is you'd create a
jenkins file and you'd come in here and
i'm going to use this
you come in here and
you declare
your jenkins pipeline
you want to test
make sure there's no errors or bugs
you'll want to build it
and then you'll deploy it
and over here in jenkins they're
referred to as stages
whereas tucked on their tasks
and within each of these stages you'll
have your steps
which is really the meat of what you're
trying to do it's where you have your
scripts your commands your arguments
parameters
it's held in the steps
so as you can see
looking at the structure it's already a
little different we've got a three-part
pipeline defined in one file while over
here we've got about six different files
so
the jenkins file lets you configure not
only your pipelines but you can do a lot
more other things in here for example
you can define functions like
exporting archives or security functions
that you want to run throughout your
process there is methods uh for example
for authentication there's a method
called credentials
where you would define in here
and
this deals with secrets and
authentication
for
firing off the pipeline
similar to the event listener and
techton there's a concept in here called
web hooks which
very similar you would program it to
listen to specific events for example
your developer committing code changes
or creating a pull request
you'd you define it like so
and once that event happens
your web hook would fire off your
pipeline
okay
so
storage
conceptually
jenkins and tektron are pretty similar
they use jenkins uses file systems just
like techton
but when we think of storage with
jenkins
they organize their directories a little
different so
jenkins has this home directory called
the jenkins home
and inside this directory
you'd have a lot of other directories
where you'd store your
build logs your configurations your
artifacts
for example there's a plugin directory
where you'd store your plugins or you'd
have a secrets directory where you'd
store your secrets
but most importantly
i think the workspace directory
is where
you'd work with the most
and the workspace directory is your
working directory wherever you run your
pipelines so
every time you run a pipeline
it's build
generates some artifacts which
think of it as files or images it's kind
of like outputs in tecton and you have
these artifacts and you want to use them
in your next run or your next stage and
so you got to save them in your
workspace so that they're not wiped out
completely with the next
build you would do so by storing it in
your workspace or archiving it elsewhere
okay
so now that we've got a good
understanding of the two you can kind of
see how conceptually jenkins and techton
are very similar at the end of the day
they're just trying to automate the
software development lifecycle they're
just trying to make a developer's life
easier by getting rid of all the manual
steps as much as possible
let's review a little bit about what i
just went through the biggest
differences so
the biggest difference is one tecton
runs on kubernetes allowing you to
easily scale your workloads to
enterprise levels
while jenkins runs on its own servers or
vms it's java based and it uses plug-ins
to extend its capability
number two
jenkins or sorry techton
it organizes each component of its
pipeline into its own file making it
very
organized and
easy to
easy to pinpoint while jenkins
uses one large jenkins file to store its
configurations and and configure its
pipeline
and then lastly
going off of this file structure
the fact that tecton divides or
organizes each file into its own entity
it allows it
it to be fully portable so once defined
anybody in your organization can come in
and reference your your pipeline
resource it resource and use it in in
their own pipeline making it very
efficient for them and not having them
reinvent the wheel every time
whereas jenkins it's a little less
organized and it's not as easy to
pinpoint exactly what you're trying to
reuse
so i hope that helped
thank you so much if you have any
questions please drop us a line below
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please like and subscribe
and don't forget you can grow your
skills and earn a badge with ibm cloud
labs which are free browser-based
interactive kubernetes labs